so i've been a fan of your podcast for a
long time
you don't often talk about it because
you're always kind of looking forward
but
if you look at the old studio they just
left is there some
epic memories that stand out to you that
you like you almost look back i can't
believe this happened
oh yeah almost too many of them to count
is that something that pops into mine
now all of them elon musk blowing that
flamethrower in the middle of the
hallway i've got a video of that
have you ever seen the video of it yeah
yeah i think you posted instagram i
think i did too
yeah he's a madman um having bernie
sanders in there
uh you know just uh all the fun fight
companions we did
and all the crazy podcasts with joey
diaz and duncan trussell and
there were so many there were so many
moments you know it's um
podcast is this is a weird art form
and it almost seems like it sounds silly
but it almost seems like something that
chose me rather than i chose it
i think of that all the time in some
strange way it's like i'm i'm showing up
as like an antenna and i just plug in
and twist
twist on and then i i take in
the thing and i put it together and i'm
like a passenger of this weird ride
yeah you you've talked about this before
i really like this idea
of that human beings are just carriers
of these ideas
yeah ideas are the ones who are breeding
yeah in a sense like the idea found you
as a useful brain to use to spread
itself through the podcasting medium
yeah something that that's a
on the but because when i think about
your podcast i think about joey diaz i
think about all those comedians you've
had
i mean i think you've had joey on i mean
maybe close to
50 times some crazy number is there
i mean he is over-the-top offensive
just that's who he is to the core is
there
some sense where you
you wondered like whether it's right to
have
the spotify episode number one with
duncan dressler
for five hours well i wanted to do it
that way that's why we wore nasa suits
and
we got high as [ __ ] it's like that's the
whole idea behind it
i mean can you introspect that a little
bit like can you think like what is that
because that's rare
it's it's such a rare thing to do
because they they're
you're not supposed to talk to duncan
trussell
with a huge platform that you have five
hours why not
because donald trump apparently watches
your podcast
so so just the idea that there's these i
mean that's what i think about
you know these ceos write to me that
they listen to the podcast
that that i do and i have somebody like
a david fravor
and i was nervous about it i was nervous
to have a conversation for me
david fravor is a duncan trussell which
is like
just because of his experiences with the
ufos
yeah just even just the way he sees the
world because he is open
i don't know if he's always like this
but he opened himself to the possibility
of unconventional ideas most people in
the scientific community kind of
say well i don't really want to believe
anything that doesn't have a lot of hard
evidence right
and so that was to me like a step and as
the thing somehow
becomes more popular that it becomes
this fear of like
well should i talk to this person or not
and i mean you're an inspiration and
saying like do whatever the hell you
want
you have to well first of all
i have what you call [ __ ] you money and
if you have [ __ ] you money you don't say
[ __ ] you what's the point of having the
[ __ ] you money
you're wasting it like you're wasting
the position like someone
said to me like why do you why do you
like sports cars so much like how many
cars you have
a bunch of cars so because if i was a
kid and i said hey if i was that
crazy rich famous guy like i don't want
to have a bunch of cool [ __ ] cars
like so i so i would do that like
because
not everybody gets to do that like if
you're the person that gets to do that
you're kind of supposed to do it like
that's if you if you want to
if that really does speak to you and you
know i've talked to you about this
before but muscle cars
specifically once from the 1960s and
early 70s they speak to me in some weird
way man i can just stare at them
like i have a 65 corvette i walk around
it sometimes at night when no one's
around
what's your favorite muscle car like
what's your
most badass late 60s the probably that
car
probably that's 65 corvette yeah i walk
around it when no one's around
i think i'm during the 69 corvette is
there a particular year that
uh just 65 is uh generation two
69 is generation three 69 is like the
it's even more curvy they're both
awesome just awesome in different ways
but i just love muscle cars for whatever
reason
but but the point is like i like what i
like and if i can do what i want to do i
should do what i want to do and it's not
hurting anybody
and the thing is like i would do the
duncan podcast if no one was listening
right
right if it was if we were just starting
to do a podcast together
and uh no one cared and got like 2 000
views which
we did for years a long time i would do
it with duncan and we would get high and
we'd talk crazy [ __ ] about aliens and
spaceships and
maybe dude maybe ideas are living life
forms and they're inside your head and
that's how things get
man yeah man i've been just kind of
morphed me and him together in that
you